we were gonna get to Cuba and we ran out
of time and I know you want to disagree
with me and you don't even know what I'm
gonna say well I want to hear what do
you have to say well I mean I think I
said in the monologue we we have
somewhere in this show we have stood
with worse dictators
I think Cuba in the freedom watch list
is 62nd out of 177 countries one being
the worst yeah so it's it's behind China
I think Iran Egypt which is not a great
place to be but it's ahead of a number
of our allies like Bahrain and Saudi
Arabia so I guess where I'm coming from
is that the United States has all the
leverage in this situation and if you're
looking at what role Castro's plan is I
believe the plan is not to do what China
and Vietnam have done not to have a kind
of you know basically move away from the
socialist economy I believe they're
looking to Vladimir Putin they're
looking to you know Chavez's Venezuela
they want to have sham elections and he
wants to install his son or his
son-in-law
and power and we're allowing that to
happen now we have all the leverage I
believe we should open up to Cuba and I
believe we should normalize relations
well we can we can demand a lot more
because they're at the most vulnerable
point we're going on for 50 years it
hasn't been going on because what I'm
saying is that actually we should open
up but we can now demand more from them
in terms of how they treat their so say
and also having an open and competitive
political these things take time
the procedure takes its week but we're
never gonna have a more leverage than we
do right now you Jesus to Russia and
Venezuela for exact cash for cash now
they can't they're 90 miles away that's
lemon the world's largest economy and if
they open the door a little crack we're
gonna overwhelm and there I feel very
comfortable that in five years time yes
guys are gone after years of sanctions
wasn't there that's look I mean he went
why is it it went
I looked at Raul Castro he spoke to the
Cuban people he talked about democracy
him and that's the first Castro family
they're not idiots they know what
they're doing they've given this a lot
of thought and if they believe that Ian
was right if they didn't they have a
plan B that's my point their plan B is
sham elections in 2018 it's already too
you know we can't make everybody in the
world do everything we've got to do
again of course we can make out
or do hand oh of course we can't but the
point is that why surrender all of your
leverage when they're at their weakest
point Oliver bridge we're true and if
you never we can never work trying
something in if it's furniture is
different tactic from the one that
didn't work for 60 [ __ ] years that
what a crazy idea the tactic is let we
have one big care to offer that is
normalizing relationships and actually
offering them the huge economic
opportunities that ending the embargo
would be another big carrot yeah yeah
we're not doing that even though most
Americans are for doing normalizing
relations is a rather big thing and
having Starwood and having Airbnb sign
deals and getting hard currency is a
hands of the repressive apparatus akin
to change they're gonna star woods gonna
be there they're gonna meet a married I
worked it that's working Putin's Russia
that's worked you know that's gonna work
in Iran I mean it's that's gonna work in
all the other authoritarian countries
where they figured out they're smart too
bill they are strategic to they've given
this some thought and they think they're
gonna come out ahead and I think their
problem right all right what that said
do any of you have a good cigar connect
cuz I just started this is manutaki what
I care about
were they what are the chances of
delegates turning on Trump if there is a
brokered convention in July
anything pretty good right I think
pretty good too yeah I mean it depends
on who those delegates are they're
working them now yeah and everybody on
the other team are you in the usual your
delegate I'm not a super delegate and I
wouldn't be on that side but I know that
they are working on it for the Democrat
know you're not a super delegate I used
to be when I was governor banana anymore
oh are you a delegate I'm not a delegate
no just a watch it's regular citizen Wow
I'm very surprised uh will the new voter
ID laws being introduced in key states
across the country influence the outcome
of the election [ __ ] yes yes I'd like to
did in Arizona's everybody who was white
that was I that hours ago total fiasco
they went from 200 polling sites to 60
in a in a heavily Latino County people
had to wait in line for five hours
wouldn't it be great if the Supreme
Court just once went yeah we got this
wrong well you know we gutted the Voting
Rights Act we thought America was
better than it was and it turned out we
could not have been more wrong is there
any argument on the other their problem
is that when we talk about voter ID laws
you've got very different laws in
different states some of those laws
Pennsylvania for example that's a really
bad law but then if you're looking at
Rhode Island you're looking at Tennessee
you're looking at other states they're
not all the same so the problem is when
we talk about voter ID laws we're
talking about a bunch of different
permission they're all rather all
four-lane nine states since 2010 have
adopted more restrictive make it more
difficult to vote laws twenty-one states
have this will be the first presidential
election for 16 of those states they're
largely in the south they're largely
trying to affect minority to quick
points two quick points one is this is a
solution looking for a problem that
doesn't exist and increase tricking
votes it's bad but the but the unspoken
truth that's happening America and the
one the biggest disenfranchisement we've
seen since we were fighting on the
Edmund Pettus Bridge and others were
fighting on the for voting rights is the
disenfranchisement is going on of people
who've been convicted of nonviolent drug
offenses we right now have a country
where the drug war the drug war is not a
war on drugs its war on people
particularly poor people particularly
minorities and so now you have a nation
where you have swing states like
Virginia and Florida were one out of
every five african-americans has lost
their right to vote and so we have this
outrageous reality in this country right
now we're a prison population since 1980
has grown 500% federal prison population
800 percent more people in jail today
for nonviolent drug offenses and all the
people in jail for 1975 being locked up
for doing things the last two presidents
said they're doing and now they're in a
second-class citizenship a caste system
where they can't get jobs they can't
vote they can't get Pell grants they
can't get food stamps they can't get
housing public housing they've entered
this caste system and it's an affront to
our democracy because basically what
we're doing is millions of Americans
we're cutting them out taking away their
voice and their participation in our
country so yeah what he said well look
and you're also conservative
and liberals for agreeing on this and
we're seeking to reform that's not it
not a parsonage this is I'm partnering
on legislation with everybody from
allies from the Koch brothers to others
trying to fight something a system
that's completely broken absolutely
destroyed he's going on in our country
right now is that what we are doing to
entire communities like the one that
I've lived in for the last 20 years is
we're devastating these communities a
chance for an african-american to be
arrested and by the way no difference
between blacks and whites for using
drugs no difference for dealing drugs is
here for some studies show that young
white men have a higher rate of dealing
drugs and blacks but an african-american
will get arrested for drug crimes about
four times more than one this actually
might make communities more dangerous
that's the really scary thing because if
you want to be tough on crime it turns
out that actually using the car
serration too much you actually change
the dynamics in these communities in
ways that make them more dangerous for
the people who live there and that is
really really bad I used to deal drugs
did you I did not deal drugs right there
anecdotal a driver and I deal drugs draw
what's that did you ever deal drug no
but back in my day I was known as an
excellent bagger
you used to deal drugs Oh in college yes
well yes yes I was gonna say just I was
gonna say just pot but that would be a
lot I mean when I got out of college it
was just pop college it was whatever my
dealer so you would buy from your deal
you were like a middle man you buy from
your dealer and he'd sell them how
that's not very nice I thought of myself
as an entrepreneur haha middleman um
that's the toy is this I hate the army
no but it still goes on today look I
would when I went to Stanford they're
like through college don't worry well
there's no drug use gonna marry you you
paid your way through college stealing
drugs yeah that's a Wow yeah maybe I'm
gangsta now
for the record for the record still no
interesting why cuz I'm white yeah I
kind of a little bit no no your gangster
five billion gangster work accident you
is Donald Trump Ian Bremmer off base and
suggesting that the us rethink its
involvement in NATO you know what let's
ask a different question that's close to
that Trump said this week that he was
not putting nuclear weapons off the
table dealing with Isis cuz we need to
be unpredictable you know you had me at
Trump and nuclear weapons have you got
VIP that's all but I mean it's true
that's a crazy thing to say well I mean
I would say number one Trump's slogan is
not make America great again it's
America first and it's let's find
everyone else to blame Mexicans are
going to come to rape our women Japanese
some Chinese are robbing us blind the
Europeans are taking advantage of our
good will on security Muslims are all
going to blow us up
that's that's a problem right and we see
that with NATO as well but I have to say
at least from my perspective I I think
the likelihood that Trump actually could
win a general election given the
astonishing negatives he has among young
among women among just normal Americans
is is really really low and I know we're
talking about it because we have to and
it's entertaining but I just I just
don't entertaining he could be the
Republican nominee and probably will be
and by the way in this country the
Republican can always win you know they
always said well you know the
Republicans are losing minorities and
they're losing women yeah but they never
try to race war election yeah they never
like really roused up those people who
when you lift up the rock you find out
what's living in this country and Obama
got like 40-something percent of the
white vote against Mitt Romney Trump's
gonna get more behind that Mary he's
depression less nine percentage points
behind Romney among white voters but
what I will say I'm Trump is yes in a
general election yeah he's well behind
Romney among white but on somebody loses
others
if she's gonna move to the middle that's
the look I sight why this is no art I
don't think he will move to the middle
no I don't know how to do that again no
how did adjust I think that he's who he
is you come at Ted no I'm talking about
it's hard
no no Trump no Teddy will know how to
move to the middle ground II will not
knows only one speed I'm the best no he
will say stuff that is appeal is not you
know obligated to be consistent no one
excited exactly right seventy percent of
women for example can't bear the thought
of voting for Trump in a general
election all women he's gonna say yes
but he's gonna he's gonna try to figure
that out remember he's super smart he
went to Wharton so so he's gonna try to
figure out a language that makes him
more palatable to groups he's gonna do
that and that's what he might do is if I
ever done that what he might give us
remember stand up serious blow to the
Republican Party one hearing where he
got more reasonable he calculatedly said
you know what I think I'm gonna be says
that he doesn't want to see poor people
out in the street he doesn't he wants to
have health care for everyone I mean he
said that right no I said the thing
about trade which is a democratic
position often and he thinks that we
should be creating jobs in America he
has said stuff that is appealing to to
my side of the aisle and I think that he
will yeah I mean he he will he will try
to moderate he's constitutionally
incapable of not doing crazy but when
he's in front of a camera right that's
the point
yeah teleporting song at AIPAC reading
from a teleprompter
we saw him being disciplined right you
know it happened once I'm doing yes they
[ __ ] it up anyway yeah one little
thing went ahead what's interesting
about Trump I've never seen white people
scramble before well I've never seen
like white America really like confused
and like what the [ __ ] are we gonna do
about that it's very interesting it's
very intriguing like Donald Trump I've
compared Ahnold Trump to me is is like
white Hurricane Katrina it's like we
Eliza was gonna be we did the levees
have broken and everyone is panicking
right now and it's very it's interesting
to watch I love it too but but here's
the thing here's the thing
Ashly it's gonna be worse for you I'm
from the hood I don't trust anybody
I think everybody's cool but you don't
think it matters if Trump is or any but
of course it matters I mean it
definitely met I'm just saying it's an
intriguing thing to watch like I mean I
think you know I've had a healthy
mistrust of literally every candidate
that ever existed in my lifetime so I'm
like yeah he's in the pile with me of
Abama um with Obama and listen we were
all very excited we're all very we were
young we're excited we were very happy
you know and then until Cory runs you
know we're just gonna hang
when it's not gonna be my about to chime
in and say that these are the days where
I'm gonna run but not necessarily for
something more like from something but
but you're gonna give the white people a
turn and they're gonna [ __ ] it up and
then you're gonna be like gonna be like
come on so Obama was pretty good you
miss him the first time I was on the
show you mean you said that hey this
Obama if he gets this thing right you
remember this joke don't you
then they're gonna think these black
guys are good at this thing like
basketball look at that was the first
that was my introduction at his show and
here eight years later it I was
suffering through thank you very much